Mike McCarty Rob hammering hey dude we
have a Just Cause 3 collector's edition
we're gonna box this baby out
oh dude that's a deep cut Jesus Christ
that this is just gosh let's take a look
inside cool what we got day one edition
Just Cause 3 comes with more destructive
vehicles kind of it looks like a combat
buggy minigun racing boat and a rocket
launcher sports car rocket launcher
sports car the other James Bond drew
that is cool I would like that
the art of Just Cause 3 got characters
some like some concept art Medici the
island of the island the official map of
Just Cause 3 was a poster on its it of
course it's a it's a double sided huge
map I've already lived this in this
island yeah look at that with the
grapple Rico Rodriguez very cool now we
got be Just Cause Rapala ain't all
plastic reacts an actual metal tether
here could you wear it no my hands up my
hands are too fat so big news real quick
I used to be a Lego maniac
was that wrong I'll spin it this way
there's no indents of his nose no there
are in this been here eight years
boom grab boom baby and that's the Just
Cause 3 replica grappling hook
you